I don't know why anyone would subject
themselves to this
this show by the way
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Julia Louis
Dreyfus she's one of the most decorated
figures in television history a
recipient of the Mark Twain Prize for
American humor as well as 11 Emmys for
her work across Seinfeld The New
Adventures of Old Christine and Veep she
also stars in the new Nicole holloff
Center directed dramatic comedy you hurt
my feelings in theaters May 26th Julia
Louis-Dreyfus welcome to the show well
thank you
hahaha
peanut though how are you around spicy
food before we get started um I'm not I
I like a little bit of spice so I'm
guessing this is not going to work out
well for me well there's only one way to
find out are you ready to get started
yeah
[Music]
you don't have a spit bucket or anything
we do Yeah we actually do good you got a
lot of stuff going on well are you gonna
eat it too I'm right here with you
cheers cheers cheers Julia
foreign
yeah that's pretty good there we go I
like that
yum here comes a little burn but it's
good
that's the classic Hot Sauce ladies and
gentlemen
so a new film you hurt my feelings you
played the role of Beth a novelist who
overhears her husband giving harsh
feedback to her latest book forcing her
to question not only her work but also
her relationship yes
Phil marks your second collaboration
with director Nicole Hollis Center what
is it about her style of Storytelling
that makes her such a sought after
director well
um I think that Nicole hollif Center's
voice is is a unique voice
um in film making
um she really knows how to straddle both
comedy and drama at the exact same time
and she also is an amazing writer of
dialogue and her exploration of
relationships are profound actually
my I'm going to tell you my lips are
burning from uh from the first one okay
so this is some other one yeah yeah the
uh the other one we have a Cree Verde
here in the two spot okay and I'm
assuming these all just go up in hotness
yeah that's exactly how the show is
designed
laughs
[Music]
I don't think this is much hotter than
the first one okay did you like hot
sauce before you started this show or
did you learn to love it I learned to
love it I learned to love it so when we
first started the show I didn't think I
don't think we thought we'd be
programming it you know I think we
thought it might be kind of a quarterly
sort of Super Bowl like internet event
oh yeah you know what I mean but then
once it started happening you kind of
buy into the concepts
and you know how it goes and then here
we are 21 Seasons later still doing it
still doing it it's unbelievable thank
you thank you yeah it's been a it's been
a grind But to answer your question I
had to learn to love hot sauce but now I
do but now I do
from a day in the life of Joe egg to
three Penny Opera is there a student
production that you did while at
Northwestern that you think
disproportionately shaped you as a young
performer
um I would say
um
to Christ I would say that I'm thinking
because I feel like my brain I'm like
you're jumping back to college and it's
hard for me to remember but I um I did
an improv show while I was at
Northwestern called the meow show yeah
and that was the show that that changed
my life dramatically
dramatically it was born out of making
fun of the WAMU show which is pretty
straightforward sort of musical comedy
review kind of a show and it I I don't
I'm not dissing it in any way but meow
was like
um just a parody of it in a sense it was
borne out to be sort of a
um you know
anti-anti that
okay
[Music]
yeah this got a little more burn I can
feel that but I'm fine I see it
everybody relax
you know I was supposed to do this show
three years ago I know with Will Ferrell
with Will Ferrell
um but I was
really sick
really sick you know because that's
always the thing when you do it you know
no no I mean I I was truly sick
so you're very lucky I didn't come on
your show
so earlier this year you launched wiser
than me a podcast where you talk to
icons like Carol Burnett Jane Fonda how
would you describe your general approach
to these conversations and what if
anything did you learn from being on the
other side of the interview
ah
you know what it's hard yeah yeah do you
find it hard I like being on this side
of the table rather than your side of
the table have you been on the other
side of the table Yeah and why don't you
like it I feel a responsibility like I
got to keep the tent up or like the ball
up in the air right but you don't feel
it now because you should feel it now
that's what I feel now in the seat I
like that but when I'm a guest I also
feel that and then how annoying is that
as a guest you know that's what I'm
saying yeah but I feel it too as a guest
okay yeah I feel enormous responsibility
let's just both take our foot off the
gas yeah [__] it you know who cares who
cares about this
whether it's Jane Fonda's Life review
method or Amy Tan's vow to do things
that scare her including Swimming with
Sharks yes is there a piece of wisdom
that you've soaked up through this
experience that you've done applied to
your own life
uh no is a complete sentence I like that
very much that's a really good one I
think it's a good one especially for
women if I may be so boldness to say
that I think women have a tendency to
apologize too much
um and um or apologize I should say
inappropriately
um and then by the way I'm so sorry if
I'm go I'm not kidding
and then
um Ruth Reichel was talking about the
critical importance of doing things that
really do frighten you
that maybe you're not quite even
prepared for in certain circumstances
and that was uh that's I think that's
good advice under under you know in
certain situations right like if you're
not so much of a hot sauce person but
I'm sure you are taking on the world's
spiciest wings for example exactly and
of course you could make terrible
mistakes
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is a little bit like going to a
wine tasting in the sense that it all
stays alive
hmm
why did I take such a big bite of this
because you're brave and you're facing
the things I'm facing the thing this is
getting too hot
okay mm-hmm
it's a little hot yeah now we're moving
away from wine pairing a little bit and
we're just into like
waterboarding or something like that
gasoline tasting you know gasoline
flakes
so for my money Veep is one of the great
Ensemble comedies of all time and I'm
really intrigued by your research
process to take on the role of
disgruntled vice president Selena Meyer
was there a job inside the capitol
that's maybe not always available to the
public eye that you found to be
especially intriguing or absurd
there's the role of the scheduler
um and I think that's kind of amazing I
I remember that we were talking to the
scheduler of a particular uh senator
and she was saying that she sleeps she
was saying this was Pride okay that she
sleeps with her
cell phone on the pillow next to her
in case her Senator needs her in the
middle of the night oh that sounds bad I
didn't mean it like that but in case
there's an issue because he's in
different time zones Etc et cetera and
she said it uh boastfully I thought that
was amazing yeah
okay
I'm taking a little bite this time
little shoulder shrug no problem
I don't think that one's an issue
but I feel like I'm gonna go
by these guys right
I think so yeah I think so and that's
just me being honest with you you know
yeah just being honest with you no I
appreciate honesty you know and I'm yeah
I'll let you know I'll let you know uh
when we get to sort of the dorm room
prank region of the show which is coming
up but in the meantime actually green
segment on our show called explain that
gram we do a deep dive on our guest
Instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context so we'll pull the
picture up over here on the Monitor and
then you just tell us the bigger story
God
from the perspective of someone who
fears horses what was it like to shoot a
scene with a horse terrifying
and you know what this [__] [__]
horse knew I was scared
really it did not want to come near me
it's interesting it's like backing away
and I was and you were backing away I
was very uncomfortable yeah
although I will say I think the jodhpurs
and the boots and the jacket are pretty
it is a look it works it works right one
more for you after three plus decades in
the entertainment industry what was the
most novel movie Magic experience that
you've had so far on a Marvel set
this
and the reason is
that if you've seen wakanda forever
there's the scene that I'm in is meant
to be on a bridge in Boston
uh and we and that is the bridge and you
can see how much green screen is
everywhere it's all CGI the entire thing
and oops sorry and if and if you I was
watching think God this is incredible I
mean we were just on pavement in the
middle of Atlanta
yeah the things they can do it's crazy
show business
[Music]
the spicy shark
it starts off kind of nice
almost kind of pumpkiny
and then yeah and then that happens
right right
I do not care for them I do not like
that I get it yeah I get it I don't know
why anyone would subject themselves to
this this show by the way no but why
would anyone eat that
you know some people are wild as I think
you'll find a little bit further down
the line but you're doing great you're
doing great I am doing great thanks
so I was once reading an interview with
Jason Alexander where he remarked about
how tiny the Seinfeld set was saying if
we knew that we were doing a series for
nine years you would never build that
set Elaine Venice is obviously a very
physical character do you have any
memory of being challenged by the square
footage the dimensions on set
boy well yes what we were always
challenged by was uh as soon as you walk
into the apartment what are you supposed
to do what business am I going to find
to do in this apartment and you're not
just going to come in and sit on the
couch every time you had
oh that's right we caught I mean you had
the couch you had the kitchen
and then you had that the sort of The
Sweet Spot we kind of I think we called
the alleyway which was sort of between
the counter and the couch and that was
where a lot of stuff happened it felt
like you could hold Court there in a way
but you also had to figure out what you
were going to do which is why I often
would go to the refrigerator and just
find things or even just go and look in
the refrigerator and not do anything but
just
um it was we were limited but we had to
be um creative about it yeah it was
interesting
what's it called jalapeno Chico
you go first all right all right
is it always the same ones
so each new season believe it or not
you're in the 21st season because I
enjoy this one
um we go out with the old in with the
new
every time
so this will get its 12 episode run you
know
the sauce I'm not gonna like this at all
I know and you know immediately and you
know immediately it's just awful mm-hmm
how jalapeno Chico
what's the point
what's the point I think like do you not
want to taste food anymore I mean it's
just
Flame
no that one I know is gonna be a
[__] I can tell looking at him
by the way are you allowed to swear on
this show you can let it fly oh okay you
can let it fly you can let it fly
[Music]
okay so I've had the opportunity to ask
I'm actually sweating it's okay it's
okay you know what it comes down from me
too you know I get a little head high
off of it we're gonna come out of this
just completely different people
yeah okay go ahead okay do you have like
a very specific internal barometer to be
able to decide whether or not
something's going to be funny or is it
always just a leap of faith
oh I have a barometer yeah I have a um
an instinct for
um
I mean I
I that sounds arrogant actually because
I don't mean I always know but I have an
ear for it and I have a an instinct for
uh what is funny like on the page
foreign
but by all means let's talk more about
my career
I'm firing my publicist not the first
time I also want a lawyer now
how do you get rid of this spicy in your
mouth after all of this is there any way
to do it or is it like I'm permanently
not permanently disfigured no no not
permanently not permanently it's gonna
suck but then in like 15 minutes you'll
forget it even happened you know what I
mean
miserable experience lovely memory okay
you take a bite all right I will
not to psych you out right
and you'll know him
immediately
yeah that's not great I know the worst
okay
[Music]
oh yeah right
okay
yeah
laugh all of you laugh that's fine
oh my God yeah all right go ahead ask me
another question and quick all right so
when we had Nick Kroll on the show yeah
he called Oakwood Apartments which you
lived in the year after you left SNL he
called them one of the sadder places in
the world what was your experience like
living in that famed Haven for
struggling actors
sad it was it was not great
oh my God
I really I'm sweating this is crazy yeah
it is it is um it is
okay are the next two gonna be worse
you remember how I've been I've been
honest the whole time no no no no no no
no sauce is as hot as the sauce that you
just ate I say that in my long storied
history with hot sauce okay well we've
got you on film saying it you know it's
the worst hot sauce I've ever had in my
life and I think it'll be the worst hot
sauce that you ever have in your life
but that if that's at all comfort
okay
um I don't know what did you just ask me
the apartments the apartments yes not
great I lived there for a couple months
during
what they called pilot season which I
don't even think they have anymore
because everything's so whacked but um
you know I'm still dying you know I know
I know I know because it's supposed to
get it better it just you know you know
I think I mean this when you're in the
storm I know I get any report in a storm
you know
we give them milk mustache I have one
now you don't good looking out thank you
I got your back Sean okay and I got
yours
you know I haven't had milk in a long
time that's great it kind of did it take
you back again
and just in time
for the next hot sauce this is the
watermelon ghost
okay
you go I will go I'll go first
oh you took a big bite look at you I
know I don't know why I did that
immediately a mistake
[Music]
thank you
okay no turning back
here we go there we go
[Music]
now no fun
kind of strange
[Music]
but after the bomb see
yeah okay here we go yeah as a long time
champion of the cause what would you say
is the most underrated National Park
oh
um
what is the most underrated National
Park
there's a Crater Lake National Park I've
never and I but I've never been there so
how do I know but it's on my list I have
a list and it's on my list because it's
really cool looking
[Music]
um I am not going to do what you do
don't yeah yeah that I think is for the
best and don't you worry about it oh I'm
not worried at all
okay so here we go Cheers Cheers
[Music]
oh that has bite immediately
right but the good news is
good news is Julia Louis-Dreyfus what
the wings of death are behind us okay
yeah we have kind of a God I know I know
I know a low lift oh my good obstacle
here to close things up oh my God in
Reading interviews with director Nicole
hollif center it's clear that she has a
special place in her heart for your
facial expressions I also read that she
brought a fart machine to the enough
said set and you and James Gandolfini
would compete with each other for who
could make the funniest face while using
it but that's a different conversation
for a different day and a different
skill set
All I'm gonna do is point to a sauce and
you tell me what it was like to eat that
sauce only using facial expressions okay
okay
the bomb Beyond Insanity
[Music]
the classic chili maple
in the last AB Apollo the one that you
just ate
[Music]
and there you have it Julia Louis
Dreyfus taking on the wings of death and
living to tell the tale now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you this camera this camera
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life
well hello America
[Laughter]
in my movie you hurt my feelings
theaters starting May 26th pleased to
enjoy
thank you so much I do not care for hot
sauce
set it in stone verdict is in the
verdict is in thank you thank you thank
you but you did so good you did so good
I did do so good I was a little you have
to be proud of yourself well yeah there
you go laughs
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans if you've ever watched hot
ones and wondered to yourself how hot
are those sauces really I can get
through that with no water or milk well
now is the time to put your money where
your mouth is the hot ones season 21
lineup is now available in its entirety
at heatness.com heatness.com that's
heatness.com to get your hands on the
season 21 hot Ones hot sauce lineup milk
not included be careful around the eyes
and get them while they're hot
mother